la maison de l'europe des yvelines au
pays des vikings
la délégation française du programme
ride il a passé trois jours en suède
read it un projet européen financé par
le programme erasmus plus avec comme
objectif d'échanger sur les politiques
publiques et actions citoyennes mises en
place dans les zones rurales dans tous
les villages où les communautés qu'on a
pu visiter et des témoignages qui nous
ont été présentés on voit de très jeunes
femmes investi en politique des
personnes âgées encore hyper actif dans
leur communauté et une vraie volonté de
travailler ensemble et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut être très
inspirant pour nous ce qui est frappant
en suède notamment c'est l'espace qui
l'on est la difficulté qu'ils ont les
familles à s'installer dans les zones
rurales
alors que visiblement d'après ce qu'on
nous ait ligne à une vraie demande et
une vraie volonté de venir habiter à la
campagne la campagne suédoise réserve
parfois des surprises comme cette ferme
vikings restaurer basée à or sunda une
ferme au coeur d'une action citoyenne
lisa anderson fait découvrir l'histoire
de ce territoire aux touristes suédois
et étrangers depuis le début c'était un
projet de la communauté d'agglomération
de seine viken pour essayer de faire
baisser le chômage
donc ils ont essayé de trouver des
solutions pour créer des emplois pour
les habitants
un exemple d'une initiative locale et
citoyenne les 24 personnes des
différentes délégations ont pu partager
leur expérience avec notamment le modèle
suédois
nous avons quelques informations
quelques connaissances sur la manière
dont est mise en place le développement
des zones rurales en suède que ce soit
au niveau national régional ou local
vous ne pouvez pas développer si vous
n'avez pas les zones rurales avec nous
c'est très important quand vous parlez
de développement des villes de
développement des villes c'est aussi le
développement rural
mais ce peut être difficile parfois de
discuter